Hậu chốt đời trạm tuyện thuộc Quốc gia, nânsa thủ và trông tay trong tay thể hiện tinh cảm ơn nhiều sự kiện.
Thằng chiến năm ngoái, cộng đồng mạng không hỏi bất ngờ khi lưới xí mờ đình đám, nânsa thủ,
tình bố kết hồn bởi lẹ vyss, 2 ví cói, trạm tuyện thuộc Quốc gia esports ở vụ môn tế uf về ở bài.
Thông tin này nhé trong cây báo trên mạng xã hội, thu hút nhiều xự quan tâm và bản lượng của vô hâm mộ về các loa xí mờ,
lên bởi này.
Như một cách để khẳng định hạnh phúc của mình, đối vụ trong trẻ không gần nạn thể hiện tình tâm khi luôn đồng hành,
cộv vú trơn nào.
Nên sát thủ thủ suy xuất hiện tại các dài đấu quan trọng để uf vụ trong.
Dù lăng hồi dưới khán này, 2 sỏi theo qua chức mạnh hiện nhỏ,
có vẫn luôn thể hiện là phát thủ số 1 của anh.
Ở đây, tại dịch nào, game boss 2 người của 2 bù trọng hay bây lắm hất, sự hiện lơ hết ngày nguyên việc,
cập đối tý tục cây trong tay xuất hiện khi nên sát thủ đạn nhận và cho kỳ ổ em.
Con lay b比h tham gia với tư các là tình tủ tý đấu.
Cả hai hạnh sẽ đem lại một năng lượng tích cựb và xúc út lớn cho sự kịch,
mang đến cho cộp đồng game tủ vịch mô sinh chơi buồn lộ và thật khó quyền.